[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition a dû à 7,8 journal de tva 78
tous sommes le mardi à 14 mai voici les
titres
le livre sort demain aux éditions
l'archipel céline ravenet publie
n'abandonnez jamais l'ancienne
directrice du refuge spa dr murray y
parle notamment de l'adoption du chien
nemo par le couple présidentiel ou
encore de son licenciement de la société
protectrice des animaux
céline ramener notre invité elle propose
que quelques quarante mille ouvrages de
tous styles à ses lecteurs la librairie
le pavé du canal fête cette année ses 30
ans depuis 1989 la structure est
implantée à montigny le bretonneux et 12
libraire vous y accueille l'un d'entre
eux sera avec nous en plateau et puis la
suite de notre dossier sur le football
féminine féminin les arbitres aussi
jouent un rôle important en huit ans
leur nombre a augmenté rencontre ce soit
avec natacha qui arbitre sur les
terrains yvelinois mais d'abord pour la
troisième année consécutive le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueillait une journée et
départementales aujourd'hui le vélo à
l'école 16 classes élémentaires des
yvelines qui ont pu la découvrir les
coulisses du temple du cyclisme français
et mais aussi s'essayer au bmx
aurélie rond étaient sur place mis en
place par l'éducation nationale
l'académie de versailles et l'union
sportive de l'enseignement du premier
degré cette journée dédiée aux deux
roues a réuni 450 élèves de cm1 et cm2
venus des quatre coins du département
des yvelines ils ont pu découvrir les
installations du vélodrome chaque
enseignant répondu favorablement pour
venir
faire cette rencontre sportive ici mais
avec l'obligation d'avoir mis en place
des ateliers
pour développer la pratique du cyclisme
dans la cour de l'école
durant la journée les élèves ont
également rencontré un champion de bmx à
22 ans romain racines s'entraîne depuis
trois ans à saint quentin en yvelines
en 2015 il a notamment terminé troisième
au championnat du monde junior
aujourd'hui je partage la passion je
leur explique qu est-ce que c'est déjà
un athlète et ensuite après la
présentation de la discipline
comment ça fonctionne comment fonctionne
une course comment on fait du bmx qui me
pose pas mal de questions combien de
temps durant un entraînement combien de
temps s'entraîne par semaine qu'on
adhère combien de fois et ensuite après
comment se passent les courses
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines abrite une
piste de bmx de niveau international
piste sur laquelle s'entraîne aussi des
collégiens issus de la section sportive
de la couldre à montigny le bretonneux
on leur fait des passages pour montrer
ce qu'on sait faire donc on fait des
sauts d enrouler et puis ce qui est
rigolo c'est de voir leur réaction quand
on fait des shows c'est toujours drôle
ils nous ont montré des démonstrations
et franchement c'est du bar est patent
chaque élève est reparti avec un diplôme
et pour certains une nouvelle passion
autre dispositif au collège flora
tristan de carrières sous poissy
l'établissement a mis en oeuvre depuis
trois semaines de voir fait un
dispositif lancé en 2010 est par
l'éducation nationale suivi par 23 % des
élèves de l'académie de versailles la
rectrice charline avenel est venu sur
place hier pour faire le point 150 des
456 collégiens de flora tristan sont
inscrits chaque lundi après les cours
ils prennent un goûter avant de profiter
d'une heure trente des devoirs donnés
par des enseignants volontaires
l'objectif c'est de lutter contre
l'échec scolaire et de baisser les
inégalités de l'accès au savoir les
propos sont recueillis par patrick
jacques de dixmude
c'est un collègue vraiment tout a été
pensé
d'une manière que je trouve vraiment
très intéressantes par exemple il ya un
temps où les élèves peuvent se reposer
c'est ce temps où on prend le goûter
ensemble c'est un sas de décompression
en même temps qu'il permet de discuter
entre élèves du choix des ateliers vers
lesquels ils vont aller et puis par
ailleurs dans les ateliers à une
progressivité et mises en oeuvre si on
est très autonome on va dans l atelier
si on a de l'anglais à faire on va dans
le pool des sciences humaines
si on a de la science à faire on va dans
le sens de nos troupeaux si on a besoin
de notre aide
on va d'un fond de salle il ya deux
invités sont avec moi en plateau laurent
guérin bonsoir consorts on parle avec
vous dans un instant des 30 ans de la
librairie le pavé du canal c'est à
montigny le bretonneux mais d'abord sept
sorties littéraires demain n'abandonnez
jamais 30 ans d'histoires vraies à
l'espé a qui sont publiés aux éditions
l'archipel et c'est écrit par vous
céline ravenet bonsoir bonsoir
alors dans ce livre vous vous confiez
votre amour pour les animaux votre
carrière à la spa notamment au refuge
des regrets et l'adoption de nemo ce
labrador griffon noir qui a été adopté
par le goût le couple présidentiel
c'était en 2017
mais vous revenez aussi sur votre
licenciement de l'espèce on va y revenir
dans cet entretien
pourquoi vous avez voulu raconter votre
histoire j'ai voulu raconter mon
histoire parce que j'ai
et consacré toute ma vie à la protection
animale et en l'occurrence à ce refuge
dr murray qui était un refuge
merveilleux dans lequel j'ai passé 19
ans en tant que salariés et 15 ans en
tant que bénévole et j'ai été licencié
injustement en mai 2018
suite effectivement à l'adoption du
chien du président de la république
enfin on a trouvé un prétexte pour me
licencier on va en parler dans
l'entretien revenons d'abord sur votre
histoire vous êtes né en 1972 dans la
sarthe et traite ou vous passionner pour
les animaux douce ça vous est venu
justement cette passion alors je vivais
dans un contexte familial un petit peu
compliqué pas dramatique mais un petit
peu compliqué je pense que bon javel
amour pour les animaux comme beaucoup
d'enfants mais c'est vrai que ce
contexte familial a fait que
cet amour pour les animaux vraiment
continuer dans le temps et lorsque nous
avons emménagé en région parisienne j'ai
trouvé ce merveilleux refuge der murray
où j'ai commencé à l'âge de 13 ans en
tant que bénévole entre l aspa 13 ans
était une évidence pour vous de tout de
suite voilà vous vous donnez dans cette
cause est complètement quand on me
demandait ce que je voulais faire
lorsque j'avais 17 ans et ai travaillé à
la spa
donc ce refuge vers leur ait été une
véritable révélation et je ne pensais
pas que des années plus tard j'en
deviendrais la directrice plusieurs
années plus tard dans good est devenue
directrice de ce refuge der murray vous
restez 16 ans et ce à la tête de ceux
refusant et 3,1 auparavant en tant que
conseillère en adoption
quels souvenirs vous gardez de cette
expérience le refuge des regrets quand
vous regardez cette expérience avec le
recul est ce que vous en être fier ah
ouais ouais parce qu'on faisait de
merveilleuses adoption j'étais toujours
excité de faire les adoptions
je bossais tous les week-ends j'ai posé
quatre week-ends dans 20 ans on n'a pas
eu d'enfant parce que je ne voulais pas
lever le pied je voulais être là
présente pour les adoptions c'est encore
très dur émotionnellement eux jamais de
vacances bat toute ma vie j'ai consacré
à ce refuge tout toute une vie consacrée
à ce sujet il y à part ce par ce refus
je passe le labrador griffon nemo ce
train là bas labrador griffon noir qui
fait d'ailleurs la couverture de votre
ouvrage
c'est un chien qui a été adopté par
brigitte emmanuel macron en 2017 ça a
été pas mal médiatisé cette adoption
pourquoi déjà de mettre en couverture
votre ouvrage il a une place importante
dans votre histoire ar murray mais bien
oui bien sûr puisqu'il a été le sujet de
le sujet numéro un de mon licenciement
il faut savoir qu'en 19 ans je n'ai
jamais reçu le moindre glam moindre
avertissement le refuge était encensé il
avait une notoriété on avait des gens
c'était un ballet incessant d'adoptants
qui venaient de toute la france même le
suisse de belgique d'angleterre et c est
pourquoi cette couverture parce que j'ai
été soutenu par des milliers de gens de
gens qui sont venus adopter une pétition
était mise en ligne avec cette photo qui
a recueilli pratiquement 21000
21 mille signatures qui vous a touché
énormément
c'est grâce à tous ces gens si je suis
encore là aujourd'hui sur l'adoption
c'était fin 2020 août 2010 est là vont
débuter quelques tensions en interne à
la spa qui vont conduire à votre
licenciement c'est en mai 2018 alors la
direction invoque à l'époque une faute
grave à votre encontre et celle d'avoir
euthanasié des chiens en dehors des
protocoles et aussi d'avoir falsifié des
documents l'espé a d'ailleurs porté
plainte sur ce sujet comment vous l'avez
vécu cet épisode on a senti l'émotion
tout à l'heure alors très mal il faut
savoir que j'ai été auditionné pendant
six heures suite à trois faux contrats
de placement pour lesquels j'ai pu
amener les preuves comme quoi je n'étais
pas l'origine de ces contrats de
placement
le jour où j'ai été auditionné il avait
d'ailleurs un document de la spa qui
avait été tronqué
donc oui je les ai très mal vécu ça a
été pour moi une très très dures
épreuves dans ma vie vous dites dans le
livre d'ailleurs c'est en ce lieu ce
lien avec ce licenciement pour vous le
lien direct c'est l'adoption de nemo par
le couple présidentiel d'après vous la
médiatisation et l'orchestration autour
de cette adoption n'a pas plu en interne
écoutez j'ai été convoqué trois fois
suite à l'adoption de nemo pour me
recadrer deux fois pour me recadrer
avance ce prétexte d euthanasie bon en
sachant que des états nazis on en
faisait le moins possible on était un
refuge en classe et quand même 1200
chiens par an entre 1000 et 1200 chien
moi condamné un chien toute une vie dans
une cage c'est pas mon truc pour moi
c'est pas de la protection animale
il ya d'autres chiens qui attendent des
places des chiens gentils et sociable
qui attendent leur place en fourrière et
malheureusement les chiens adoptables
prennent prennent la place de ces chiens
là et
et voilà je ne comprends pas qu'on
puisse garder des chiens à vie dans des
cages pour moi c'est pas de la
protection animale nous sommes des
centres d'adoption ne sommes pas des
pénitenciers et il faut savoir que on
j'ai reçu une lettre de licenciement
pour l'euthanasie de trente et un chien
sauf que j'ai envoyé deux courriers
recommandés parce que je sais
pertinemment qui a pas eu trente et une
taille nazis n'ont juste pas justifiée
mais hors protocole jeune et j'ai eu des
réponses mais sans la liste nous avons
envoyé un huissier de justice
quatre mois et demi après mon
licenciement dans mon licenciement était
actée depuis quatre mois et demi et
l'huissier de justice a reçu comme
réponse que la sp à continuer les
recherches
vous parliez tout à l'heure du soutien
que vous avez reçue cette pétition qui a
recueilli plus de 21 plus de vingt mille
signatures 21me signature est ce que
vous avez aussi reçu un soutien de la
part du couple présidentiel
alors je ne je ne vais pas m'étaler sur
ce bon sur ce sujet mais ils ont été
très chic avec nous d'accord vous serez
d'ailleurs
alors ça c'est pour la suite en tête de
liste des prochaines élections à la
présidence de la spa qui se dérouleront
en juin prochain
pourquoi être candidate est ce que c'est
aussi peut-être une revanche sur ces
derniers mois difficiles
ce n'est pas une revanche mais jeu c'est
notre adn c'est mon adn
la spa ça a été toute ma vie et je veux
apporter mon expérience de terrain je
veux je veux apporter toute ma passion
je n'ai aucun intérêt personnel à y
gagner
absolument pas
mais je veux apporter mon savoir et tout
mon amour toute mon énergie que je veux
donner pour la espère je rappelle que ce
livre n'abandonnez jamais sortira en
librairie demain c'est aux éditions
l'archipel au prix de 17 euros avant de
vous laisser vous vouliez passer un
appel céline il ya votre chienne qui a
disparu depuis une semaine kenya voulant
disparu depuis une semaine donc on la
cherche et on a des j'ai énormément de
soutien
il ya des gens qui se déplacent de
partout pour venir la chercher il ya une
campagne d'affichage de 600 affiches et
elle est introuvable est vraiment elle
est partie du tartre godrans dans les
yvelines et j'espère sincèrement que
nous allons les retrouver très vite pour
des raisons personnelles on peut pas me
donner votre numéro à l'antenne en tout
cas vous pouvez contacter notre
rédaction et on mettra en lien
si jamais il ya des informations à ce
sujet merci c'est juste un loupé qu'une
partie parce qu'une partie de mes droits
d'auteur iront à des associations des
dom tom et à certaines associations de
deux métropoles
merci d'être passé sur son plateau la
transition est toute faite après avoir
parlé sorties littéraires on accueille
un libraire sur ce plateau c'est laurent
guérin bonsoir bonsoir et déjà dit
bonsoir mais je vous redis bonsoir alors
vous venez pour nous parler du des 30
ans du pavé du canal vous êtes le gérant
de cette librairie qui est implantée à
montigny le bretonneux depuis 1989 c'est
dans le centre commercial sud canal 30
ans cette année ce que c'est un
anniversaire particulier important
non mais au lieu de taper les deux
halles c'est un libraire heureux que
vous recevez ce soir parce que trente
ans ça se fête oui moi ça fait cinq ans
que je suis à la tête de la librairie
donc eric arnaque qu'ils étaient avant
moi fait vraiment de très belles choses
a réussi à s'installer au coeur de
de la vie nouvelle à l'époque a réussi à
conserver ce commerce malgré la
concurrence malgré le fait que les
conditions n'étaient pas un peu
compliqué pour le livre et la culture
donc voilà donc on nous on est toujours
là on continue hélas 30 ans il faut
absolument qu'on marque ça donc on va
faire une année ce qu'on a décidé nous
ressemblent avec l'équipe c'est de
d'utiliser toute cette année des trente
ans pour faire beaucoup d'événements
culturels la rumba paso dédié uniquement
aux livres on va faire pas mal de choses
qu'on a fait venir une chorale de
montigny on va faire venir une troupe de
hip hop début 2020 on va faire à mon
avis une murder party et on va faire
aussi venir des auteurs forcément on va
travailler aussi avec des éditeurs on
voit là je pense que c'est intéressant
de faire venir des directeurs de
collection nous explique un peu leur
métier comment ils sélectionnent les
ouvrages
quels sont les travail qu'il mène avec
les auteurs donc voilà en bref voilà on
va s'ouvrir un peu les champs du
possible au niveau notre culture année
de fête pour ses 30 ans et ça vous
parler des difficultés traversées par
l'ancien directeur d'autant plus qu'il
faut le souligner la particularité de la
librairie c'est que c'est une librairie
indépendante
complètement donc oui c'est ça il ya
douze libraires professionnels on est
complètement indépendant ce soit
financièrement des institutions comme
des éditeurs donc on est vraiment libres
de nos choix que ça c'est un avantage on
est libre de vos choix
c'est ça on porte nos projets si vous
voulez donc c'est vraiment sur cette
liberté qu'en fait on peut emmener les
gens on peut leur faire leur proposer
des pas de côté on n'a pas d'imposition
fixe de la part des éditeurs ni forte
donc on a une vraie sélection qui est
fait par ces professionnels et quand on
vient dans une librairie indépendante en
fait c'est ça qu'on vient chercher c'est
déjà l'accueil le conseil et le fait
qu'on arrive à faire des pas de côté aux
gens pour leur montrer qu'il ya d'autres
choses dans le monde de la littérature
qui existe quarante mille ouvrages c'est
ça qui sont proposés salade avril ça on
a un stock à peu près de 40 ouvrages à
la neige et donc votre nous deux genres
ya plusieurs styles pour présenter tous
les domaines donc on a forcément de la
littérature la littérature étrangère du
cola on à la littérature de l'imaginaire
un gros domaines aussi qui est le pôle
jeunesse on a aussi de la bande dessinée
alors tous les la bande dessinée a
vraiment pris de l'ampleur dernièrement
parce que les romans graphiques sont
venu s'insérer un peu dans ce schéma lac
c'était assez en façade et voilà c'est
un vrai choc donné son équipe qui prend
beaucoup de place et qui est vraiment
foisonnant et et captivant et on a les
sciences humaines qui se trouve l étage
tout ce qui est sûr humaines et
développement personnel forcément se
trouve à l'étagé vous parliez de ses
douze libraires qui impriment leur leurs
patins sur cette sélection des ouvrages
sur leur spécialisation comment elle
s'opère justement la sélection des
ouvrages comment sont choisis les ça
fonctionne en fait les éditeurs viennent
nous voir trois mois à peu près avant
que ne sorte que les ouvrages il ya une
si grande qu'elle fait sur l'ensemble du
catalogue de tous les éditeurs publient
bras de premier niveau
on est quand même classé dans les 100
premières libres en france donc tous les
tous les éditeurs viennent chez nous les
livrer à fonc sonne au titre titre par
titre
ils sélectionnent les bouquins qu'ils
veulent faire entrer ce qu'ils aiment ce
qu'ils aiment moins et donc c'est comme
ça que ça c'est travailler trois mois
après donc les ouvrages arrive
entre temps on a lu les ouvrages que
l'on portait et donc c'est grâce à ça
qu'on peut faire des petites natures
enfin tous les petits mots qui sont
distillées sur l'ensemble de la libre et
c'est donc chaque libraire qui a lu les
ouvrages et qui peut on parler donc une
question qui est ouverte qui pourrait
porter au débat est-ce que d'après vous
le livre a encore un avenir face au
développement du numérique le livre en
tout cas un papier je parle oui il
fallait c'est un peu comme se poser la
question des est ce que l'humain encore
un lit un avenir vis-à-vis du numérique
bien sûr on a toute notre place monsieur
bien sûr donc on est là nous pour
proposer autre chose
forcément ça c'est rien de combat que
les grandes chaînes numériques on ne va
pas du tout faire les choses comme les
grandes surfaces on n'est pas là pour
faire pour vendre les mêmes produits
nous on est vraiment là pour dédier un
accueil aux personnes qui nous viennent
nous voir et leur montrer que voilà
qu'il yad'autres littérature qui sont
accessibles d'autres littératures que
sur un peu moins accessible on peut les
emmener aussi vers ce type de 12
ouvrages et on est aussi là pour avoir
du fond parce que les éditeurs ont
besoin des maisons de maisons d'édition
de besoins des librairies indépendantes
pour que leurs fonds de catalogue soit
toujours présent sur les sur les lieux
de vente parce que s'il n'y a plus que
des grandes surfaces
tous les fonds de catalogue
les bouquins qui ont des rotations dans
ces classes ne vont pas du tout existe
et donc tout le monde va dire exactement
la même chose ça va être complètement
sclérosé le marché va être complètement
le scanner sclérosé et nous on est donc
là pour aussi faire vivre des fonds de
catalogue on vous parlait tout à l'heure
des événements à l'occasion de ses 30
ans on peut lire trouvé bien sûr un sur
le site de la librairie qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran une dernières questions
encore ouvertes
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour
pour ses 30 ans pour cet anniversaire
eva que ça dure encore 30 ans voilà
qu'on continue qu'on arrive à s'ouvrir
aussi et qu'on devienne un vrai lieu
culturel de la ville nouvelle voilà
c'est ça que j'aime rire en fait prendre
ce virage là qu'on arrive à faire à
mixer les genres que qu'il y ait du show
qu'on ait de l'exposition de photos
voilà qu'on arrive un peu à conca tenais
tout ça agrémenté tout ça et que voilà
que savidan avec les différentes
associations de la ville nouvelle et
bien bon anniversaire à la librairie le
pavé du canal merci laurent guérin
d'être passé sur ce plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes le gérant de cette
librairie qui est implanté donc depuis à
1989 à montigny le bretonneux une petite
pause politique dans ce journal les
élections européennes se tiennent le
dimanche 26 mai et en vue de ce scrutin
nous interrogeons les représentants des
listes candidates
trois questions ce soir à jérémy de
serre lille est en quatrième position
sur la liste renaissance qui regroupe
notamment est la république en marche et
le modem les propos sont recueillis par
michael elle me donne tout simplement
parce que ceux qui la composent la
composent sont déterminé motivé sincères
dans leur volonté à la fois faire bouger
l'europe mal à faire bouger en ayant le
pragmatisme et en
se forgeant aussi l'état d'esprit sur
les réalités du terrain a tout bien
évidemment l'agriculture française ne
serait pas ce qu'elle est sans l'europe
et ne sera pas ce qu'elle sera sans
l'europe non plus par contre il faut que
l'europe reprennent un peu de courage
politique pour redonner un certain
nombre d'orientations et redonner à cap
une direction aux agricultrices et aux
agriculteurs de ce pays notamment mais
aussi aux agriculteurs européens
moi en tout cas je vais pousser pour que
l'on puisse à la fois basée aussi sur
les atouts que l'agriculture européenne
peut avoir sur la qualité de son
alimentation de son agriculture sur ce
qu'elle peut encore faire en matière
d'environnement et d'écologie
moi je pousserai ça pour faire en sorte
que l'agriculture redevienne un
véritable secteur stratégique
[Musique]
nous sommes pas inconscient sur les
nécessités de changer alors pas que le
modèle agricole d'ailleurs mais de
changer aussi notre manière de foot de
vivre notre manière de fonctionner notre
manière aussi voilà de traiter les
questions environnementales et dans
notre programme nous gérons cette
question écologique avec beaucoup
d'ambition mais avec surtout le
pragmatisme encore une fois nécessaire
qui permettra à la fois en relevant le
défi écologique de malgré tout maintenir
une certaine économie aussi sur le
territoire
et vous retrouvez l'ensemble de ces
modules consacrés aux élections
européennes sur notre site internet tv
soixante dix huit points comme à deux
informations trafic à présent vous vous
en êtes sûrement aperçu si vous avez
emprunté l'autoroute a13 la nuit est
dernière des modifications de
circulation sont mises en place entre
mantes-la-jolie epône dans le sens
province paris et jusqu'au 15 mai de 21h
30 à 5 heures du matin une déviation est
prévue via la rd 113
puis elle à l'entrée numéro 10 de
l'autoroute des travaux sont en cours
pour raccorder à laax le nouveau tablier
de guerville une signalisation adaptée
guidera les conducteurs un chantier de
nuit va également concerner la nationale
10 jusqu'au 7 juin sur la portion entre
le perray en yvelines et les essarts le
roi de 21h à 6h du matin la couche de
roulement sera renoul renouvelée dans
les deux sens de circulation
conséquences des perturbations à prévoir
des déviations et basculement de
chaussée et mis en place suite c'est de
notre fil rouge sur le football féminin
dans les yvelines elles ne sont que 1000
à arbitrer les matchs en france mais
derrière ce chiffre une augmentation est
depuis le nombre de femmes arbitres en
france a augmenté de plus de 48% dans
les yvelines
aussi le chiffre tend à monter avec le
corps arbitral qui ne représente
malheureusement encore que 2 % mélanie
poker est allé à la rencontre de l'une
de ces arbitres celui qu'on appelle
habituellement l'homme en noir ce jour
là c'est une femme natacha 34 ans
passionné de football depuis l'âge de 9
ans une passion communiqué par son grand
père depuis 2015
l arbitre comme officiel un match chaque
dimanche c'est un échange qu'on avec les
joueurs qui est privilégiée sur le sur
le terrain sa ferme et de s'affirmer
aussi et puis c'est une autre facette de
pratiquer le football même si on n'a pas
le même maillot on a forcément la même
passion et on essaie de partager ça avec
avec les joueurs aussi on n'est pas là
pour
pour les remettre des cartes ont
systématiquement mais pour que la
rencontre se passe bien pour le match
tout à l'heure il ya une équipe qui joue
en noir une équipe qui joue en vert les
gardiens gris et orange vérification du
terrain des licences échauffement plus
d'une heure avant le match natacha et
ses arbitres assistants prépare la
rencontre dans sa relation avec les
équipes natacha privilégie la discussion
je ne force pas mon caractère j'arbitre
naturellement j'ai un contact assez
assez facile avec avec les joueurs je
suis pour la communication sur le
terrain donc je pense qu'avec la
communication n'arrive à résoudre
beaucoup de conflits donc j'ai pas de
souci de ce côté là honnêtement avec les
joueurs j'habite principalement que dès
que des hommes c'est assez rare que
j'arbitre sur les matchs féminins dans
le département les femmes ne sont que 7
à officier le district compte 300
arbitres des hommes et des femmes
proposées par les clubs yvelinois en
fonction de leur niveau de compétition
si vous n'avez pas le nombre minimum
d'arbitré vous avez des sanctions pour
calculer le nombre d'arbitrés fournis
par les clubs
quand c'est une arbitres féminines elle
compte pour 2 alors là aussi on m'a dit
'ce tout discret c'est de la
discrimination oui mais elle est
positive et j'assume 1 voilà c'est pour
inciter les clubs à nous amener des
arbitres féminines aussi le district
organise chaque année deux formations
pour devenir arbitre
elles ont lieu en octobre et en novembre
natacha delhaize de temps en temps le
sifflet pour taper elle-même dans le
ballon
[Musique]
comme chaque mardi mélanie pocket avec
mon plateau bonsoir ça pour votre coup
de coeur vous avez choisi de parler
d'une oeuvre collaborative une pièce de
théâtre à découvrir en fin de semaine eh
oui qui mieux que les manifs quoi
pouvait parler de magny les hameaux
en dix d'entre eux ont répondu à l'appel
de la compagnie 7 septembre il participa
j'habite à manille c'est le titre du
spectacle à l'origine de l'idée metteur
en scène catherine l'aisne les
participants font des manies quoi donc
deux plusieurs générations de plusieurs
quartiers de la ville et y témoigne à
partir de là on essaie de composer un
spectacle à partir des anecdotes à
partir de leurs ressentis à partir de
leurs émotions à partir de leur vécu
d'habitants et ils nous décrivent la
ville je leur demande par exemple de
décrire ce qu'il se passe par leur
fenêtre ce qu'ils voient comment par
exemple aussi si il se balade dans leur
ville s'ils vont dans les autres
quartiers
qu'est ce qu'ils y font dans leur ville
et ses manies quoi elles seront sur
scène le 18 mai pour présenter cette
création qui représente un long travail
réfléchissent à tout ça depuis le mois
de novembre se retrouvant une fois par
mois environ
catherine l'aisne a à chaque fois
récupéré les textes pour les assembler
les couper de temps en temps mais
c'était aussi pour les apprentis
comédiens un autre travail savoir se
détacher de son texte
entrée sur scène un petit mot de deux
d'entre eux
je raconte d'abord voir comment je suis
arrivé à manille par mes parents et
après je raconte des anecdotes des
souvenirs et je défends si pas mal manie
comme quoi c'est l'idée de la ville à la
campagne et qu'on peut vivre aussi bien
que dans une banlieue proche de paris
moi j'y raconte donc pas pourquoi j'ai
eu pour chenu y vivre comment ça s'est
passé et puis aussi je raconte des
petites anecdotes dont une une anecdote
sur le sur le maire de magny les hameaux
alors une projection de photos de magny
les hameaux va compléter la
représentation pour découvrir la ville
autrement les comédiens seront sur la
scène de la maison de l'environnement
le samedi 18 mai avant tard merci
mélanie on vous retrouve dans un instant
à la présentation du 7-8 culture vous
parlerai notamment de la nuit des musées
et je crois du tremplin première scène
qui est organisé par le festival rock en
seine
la fin de cette édition vous pouvez bien
sûr la consulter en replay sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]